I think the main reason. In retrospect the main reason for leaving the city and coming.
Coming to nimbin and billington and such places was. Was really to live their own lives.
I think that's that's the fundamental part of it. But the. It became.
It was becoming increasingly and strongly obvious.
Living in the city living the lives that our parents' generation set up. Which included.
Sending is trying to send us to fight a war in vietnam that we fundamentally didn't believe in and. And and.
Becoming more and more involved in a society totally dependent on oil and.
Resources which couldn't be sustained at the level that we were using them.
And while they were particular things wrong with. That that way of living.
I think now that the most important thing was that we wanted to have a life of their own
and i really strongly think that every generation should do that.
So that when we came up here and we tried new forms of relationship and new forms of family
and new patterns of responsibility for children and new ways of living communally and. New forms of property ownership.
Communal property ownership and so on and. Some of those of. Just become part of the mainstream.
And some of them of being dropped altogether.
Now many of us like to have private property allow there are still some very successful.
Communal properties around and these are increasing
but now they tend to be what are called multiple occupancies where it's almost a strata title system where everyone has
the. Small block of land with a house on it and this communal ownership of one hundred acres or so of forest.
In the middle so it's a.
It's a nice combination i think of both and it's worthwhile to find out what are the things which.
Which people really need how much private property how much.
Lucidity of relationships and continuity of relationships that people need. I think when we came from the city we.
We came out of a system which was far too repressive.
And as revolutionary movements we went to the opposite extreme
and there were those of us in that generation probably coming back and finding some middle ground which suits us.
Hopefully the next generation will take off from a middle ground and then find a ground that suits them.
So that the fact that now we don't all live communally and we don't all. Continue to share each other's. Partners and.
That some of us are in monogamous relationships i don't think is in the sense of failure it was. It was worthwhile.
Testing it. Changing. To whatever extent we needed to and. Finding out for selves what. What worked for us.
That's a good thing to find out. That's a much better thing to find out than to have simply passed on to you.
Fundus memories of newman would have to be. The healing festivals in the music. Just the.
Probably my very fondest memory is being shampooed. By three or four people. Six or eight people.
All singing and chanting. Delightfully. No single personal vibes just just.
Bodily being part of a group of people in that way. The color. The color of people's dress. Costume you michael.
And just the continual music that was made by us.
And really the notion that we were doing all this we're having this marvelous magic creative. Interesting.
In a generic lifestyle and it was only. We who were doing it. And i think that's the real.
That really came from the concept the original concept of aquarius.
And that grand danson and johnny out on set up is that the festival was to be just.
To come from the energy and what people did the. It wasn't as festivals are now on.
Or even woodstock was paid bands coming from somewhere else to entertain a group of.
Consuming masses because that's the last hour we want to leave in the city.
It's boring to be in the audience and consuming all the time.
And it's wonderful to to have adventures and to do it yourself and you can. I've seen.
I've had probably the best experiences and heard the bass music in my life.
And of course a good circle gets going where that sort of energy attracts people who have studied many years
and have developed a real skills in music and art and drama and so on and those people would then.
Would come to name and we would see also that there is real value in being really skilled. Musicians but.
But there's also wonderful found in. You know homegrown musicians and eventually the to do the difference disappears.
The whole idea was to build a lifestyle in a place where. Where i suppose the base people would.
Would want to come and leave. And they did. I think in the early days of newman it was.
You had to be a bit braver in the sylph sufficient and have a bit of background. To leave. To leave the city.
And there was nothing he. So it wasn't easy in any scenes. Major in a few people came to the.
The aquarius festival and could. Without doing anything themselves kind of. You know.
Leave off take from take from the others but actually moving up here there was.
There was nothing we had to make their own relationships there and found their own music and.
And that was great but i think any people with a with a certain energy and enthusiasm. Can do that and.
I don't know about the concept of made innocent that time i was very much part of the anti psychiatry movement taking
my fourth year on a psychology students to the.
The psych hospitals and showing how they were diagnosed and brutalized and.
And that they had that wasn't necessary wasn't as necessary is. As what was happening. And.
So i don't know whether we were made i'm not sure whether we were people who couldn't cope in the city in kind of a
place where we made a last hour that we could cope with or whether we would just create even energetic and wonderful
and amazing. And the truth is probably a bit of both.
As it is we i suppose with migrants in any situation i guess migrants are the.
They're the best and the worst of any country the most creative but also the most dissatisfied.
The strongest but also the least well adjusted though i don't know about all that. And.
To a certain extent i think that. Real difficulties including possibly madness and sell and.
To some extent could be could be coped with and absorbed and used to need to grow.
And in a sort of last hour you were leading because it was.
It was travel but it wasn't organized it was the way that you could. Your energy was welcome but it wasn't.
On demand from nine to five. And i think that sort of continuity of.
Of of the presence of other people without the without. Divided demands and. Structures and. Regular demands of people.
Allows a lot more people to to adjust and be energy can give you the best and in a very ordered. Social system does.
I think too in the early days we.
We were fascinated by the differences between people between us we was very much the thought that we all had something
to offer. And if it was really really far out. That was a good thing. Certainly wasn't threatening.
You know a real freak with someone who was who was valued and. Interesting.
Rather than someone who had problems always diagnosable who you couldn't quite.
Make it all or just all control and skills. I remember sleeping when not in the dye and made of.
Of probably mud bricks and concrete. That was completely started with bottles of different colors.
So that when you lie down on the ground you looked out. Along the length of a bottle to the to the moonlight.
And the whole thing was. Was a multi colored sort of. Psychedelic haven. Done over the top of you.
And somebody lived in that. How could you judge a bit of. Good to judge whether that person was mad or just amazing.
And i think there was a lot in the eastern spiritual tradition which.
Which had a lot of trouble distinguishing between madness and spiritual. Than a spiritual craziness. And my friend.
Harry frame in the psychiatrist he announces he has a lot of trouble distinguishing between a spiritual transformation
and. An episode of medicine. And be too keen to tell which was which. Harry gumboots farley.
An amazing person in my memory harry gumboot was.
Out a tangible force where we all used to eat communally in the early days at the white house.
Every month or so the hurry christians would come around and fetus and.
Play music and we chant and sing this song that was wonderful but then we had to listen to the to the.
Ten minute speech about how the world was created two hundred sixty seven years ago
and even we couldn't take that sort of thing.
The next time they came we made up a song called harry gumboot instead of harry reid our way saying have a gun with.
And there was actually a person called harry gambit on time of of the times though it was. It was our way of a.
Thing spiritual and joining in with anything without being.
Without being silly about it and losing a sense of family and perspective. I mean even hippies.
Can't believe the world was created two hundred sixty seven years ago. Once when i was living it. Explained.
A few of us had been to thailand. To do meditation retreats and. A couple of the people bought. Time and.
Back with them. Very much a new tradition of us sitting up there and. Nice down communities and so on and.
I guess instead of building a church we bought the time and can.
Building a little down up on the top and one of the shelves of land high above the. The explained.
One of us at the time would be his. He's keepin. To look after him and.
Every morning and afternoon there would be a meditation sitting around a ton of channeling. Time monk. So that.
That's how we provided for. That was our church i suppose. Very little community for. A few years that lasted.
After that to stay in a walk in sydney. It.
And once when i asked janet chan what the secret of life was he said drink coffee
and sleep that is the secret of life drink coffee and sleep.
So if you want to have your own resident talking monkey discovered get one.
You'll find someone who always find some part of the world that will cooperate with any scheme that's got enough.
Imagination and there's got good energy to it.
There are very few people in the men who set themselves up as gurus
and there are a couple of exceptions to that statement. The world is full of gurus and it was wonderful to be able to.
To adopt garous or ideas from. Religions and practices and. And build them into one's life and in. Then build.
Just like being able to read the literature of the the world. They just ideas they just.
Ways that some people have found to broaden and deepen in the spiritual and magic. Aspects of their lives i suppose.
We had a good. We always had a good. Level of skepticism abets things.
The hairy christians have found that they're always thought of as as being pretty strange really. In the world.
It's got plenty of room for strange people.
And the world that we left in the city didn't have room for strange people in it and it was. Its loss that it didn't.
Was into diagnosing and. Excluding and and. One of the the original gurus i suppose in the city was marshall mcluhan.
And the. At a more intellectual level who wrote a book called one dimensional man.
And that was probably captured what we what we didn't like about what life was like in the city.
It was one dimensional and fitted the new you and now you didn't have ideas. We never talked about it.
One didn't talk about politics or religion. Certainly didn't talk about magical. Sexuality or drugs or. Fun.
What adventure. That was or what they did in the seventeenth century when there was a world to explore.
And suddenly with the help of some psychedelics we.
We found there was an inner world to explore and it was not really nothing to stop the suspense.
I think i think the presence of psychedelics to the beat of l.s.d. That was a randon. And some of the good dope was.
I think it was probably fundamental and basic to too. To the whole new age thing. Really i think it probably was.
I think it just let you see that there was another how. Dimension of possibilities about human life.
And then of course you could read. Eastern literature and. And some of the.
Some of the more spiritual western literature and know that people had lived.
The experience of those dimensions of life in the past and why weren't we doing it.
That birthright that's part of what we're capable of as human beings and. And we want to be able to do it.
And it probably just looked a lot easier to do it out in the countryside. Amongst ourselves.
Consenting to decide rather than to have to fight to do it and. You know a city where it was was thought out with.
With disbelief and fear and. Yes.
You get very much a sense of place of name and inversely anyone who spent any time hearings upcoming back.
Whether to stay if they can away for the just keep coming back.
There's something very magical about the fact that this is in the mountains. There's a lot of days when it's misty.
Rainy. Quite quite hubbert like. That was probably one of the. One of the. Very important bits of.
Western literature that that informed our way of life was. Tolkien spokes.
Had to read talkings books and then you'd be just a bit prepared to leave the city
and come in living in this lovely hobbit country where of the misty mountains where you can live around the mountain
from somebody else and leave. Ten minutes walk away or five minutes walk away. And. And yet.
Hardly see them and to know that there's a lot of really really magic and explored nature between you and them.
And it tangible force for example a big commune here. The whole place is joined by walking tracks.
Which go across numerous creeks and. Walking barefoot. Around tracks in the rainforest to see your neighbors.
In the misty days or in the evenings with glow worms on the way and.
Animals in the trees is just a life that's full and rich of nature and magic and spirituality and.
It's very different from living in a fibro house in bankstown. And going to sydney university to learn.
Something or other. Ok. Ok. It's similar to. It. Yeah. Yeah. Which. Tricks. Day i am and i. So.
My name's diana roberts.
Currently an alderman on this small city council which i had been for the last fifteen months or so and.
I hope honest i own my own business in women which i share with a friend or not been practicing in them
and as a herbalist on and off since i moved here. I use a god. I live on a community.
About twelve calamitous from women with nine other. Households. We have fifteen children.
Fifteen adults so we're quite a big community. And i have a five year old daughter.
About thirteen years ago when i was living in sydney.
My partner and i decided that we would really like to live to move to the bush we both came from a rural area
and i used and we'd lived in sydney for ten years
and didn't really want to be a part of that sort of environment anymore not because we didn't like it
but because we wanted to china and wanted something else. And we got together a group of people. There were six of us.
And we spent about six months looking for land. In rural areas along the coast north of sydney and.
The further we got from sydney the cheaper the land became. And we eventually found this place of land.
Name and that was a piece of land that we could afford. And that we were also able to develop as a multiple occupancy.
So that was just over ten years ago and here we are. As. Pimpernel as. It's a one hundred icas that used to be.
It probably once was dairying country. And then. As the land became more and more.
Degraded it was basically just grazing country. But it was a very sort of low grade. You know low quality pace of land.
When we moved here. We've got. I told nine families. Now. Living here.
And we've also built our own houses are in the process of building our own houses.
We are not a sort of a tight community in that we've done. Sort of eat together. And spend a lot of our time together.
However we're very sort of closely knit community in that we socialize together a lot.
We play volleyball together once away. It's a very supportive community and we're all good friends.
I'd have to say it's taken quite a long time to get to that point. We've seen people who've come and gone.
Specially in the first five years that sort of a real.
Initiation time that paypal who move on to multiple occupancies in that.
You know you have to learn to live with a group of people.
You don't have anything to live inside you're also building your houses. It's a very stressful time.
Generally for relationships because you suddenly spent.
Spending a lot of time with your partner which you might never have done before.
So it's almost like getting to know your partner you getting to know your family
and you getting to largest group of people that you've never met before and. You're living in.
You know pretty primitive conditions in the early dies and i lived.
Just a pace obtain a bat to mate his boss or a mate us a slipped in a tent with eleanor's and snakes
and you know not jumping ants and all sorts of. Interesting little crate just.
I endured about six months of almost continual rain when i first moved here which was the must.
Frustrating experience for somebody trying to build a house and get a decent roof fiver ahead. And i.
I also found myself in a situation of. Building my own house when. Prior to moving here.
And i reckon aka camp on one hand the number of times i'd picked up a hammer.
Probably never used a drill in my life and i've never ever seen a four inch nile before.
And i know all those things intimately now and have a house. To live in that.
A lot of which i built myself i'm quite proud of it. I think that the people have lived here.
Not chosen sort of different ways to build their houses. And we have some stein houses where we've sort of. Quarried.
You know made small quarries. In some in some of our hills. But generally we're all pretty comfortable. And i think.
You know happy with the last minute. It's a very sort of place and. Although very sort of.
Challenging in confronting way to live. We had a lot of struggles and nearly dies when we came here.
We had struggles with that and neighbors who were very resistant to the idea of having a multiple occupancy.
Next door and. We went through. Fairly unpleasant processes of taking neighbors.
To court until we realised that relates. You know that sort of. The legal why wasn't the light.
And it was you know much better to try and negotiate.
Solutions with neigbor so relate just to sort of let them bathe and let time sort of heal those divisions.
We also had difficult times. You know between ourselves just learning to live together.
And then we also had very difficult times. With council. We put in a development application. After we bought the land.
Which was fairly common practice in. Dies.
And still is to sight in some ways i mean you get a few developers who put in a development application.
Before they actually found the paypal.
But the many people setting up a community had all found a paypal found a piece of land
and then they put in the development application. To council.
And in those days i think we would have put ads in about eight years ago. It was a very unfriendly. Council and.
Unfriendly. Council staff.
And we had an incredible struggle trying to negotiate what we felt would raise noble conditions under which our
development could be approved. And it took us quite a few years and it cost us quite a lot of money. And once again.
You know the only options to us. In the end. Were to follow the legal process and to take counsel to call and.
We actually decided not to do that ultimately because that becomes a very different scenario once you're in court
and the actual reality gets lost in. You know in the lagos sort of jargon and practice here.
I think liz more cancels a much more friendly counsel now as far as multiple occupancy guys although this still a lot
of prejudice. Among some of the older men and stuff and i think that a lot of ignorance.
About multiple occupancy last allam want to actually manes this.
Vision of a whole lot of hippies living in substandard conditions. In the hills whereas in fact.
You know it's not like that are told and.
I've often thought it would be really valuable to take you know people on tours of multiple occupancy so they can
actually see how people live.
You know what the values are of those people
and the values of those people are no different to paypal in a lot of community. It's just there's.
These perceptions that. You know that we are different. I think on other councils that perhaps.
You know the situation isn't as friendly towards.
Multiple occupancies always easy i'm not saying it's friendly and it's not council but it's daisy.
And we saw a situation named. Caio council about three years ago where they actually demolished somebodies house.
This was a bamboo house it was a really beautiful house that had been built by a local bamboo. House build on amazon.
By a woman who had three young children and. I think the perception on the council was that.
Here we had a woman living in an illegal house that was meant to be a template dwelling. But an illegal house in.
Substandard. Sort of. Third world conditions because she had a ramdisk floor and she had a pit toilet which.
Many of us had and.
That it was a bamboo house like you see in asia and that created all sorts of sort of shock horror and.
Incredibly negative ill informed comments.
I feel from people who you know are in a position to know better and should be better informed and.
In a very sort of heavy handed way. Council came out and demolished the house. Fortunately we don't say.
You know that happening too often not there was a situation in lismore in about seventy eight might be a little bit
earlier where. Lismore canso trott demolished a couple of houses and i lost that battle in court and.
I think they've really sort of laid off since then because it costs a lot of money.
You know if it counsels to go to court. The way that we say the. Sort of prejudice coming through now is just in the.
The conditions that applies done. Multiple occupancies when they put in their development application.
The standards the canso requires of them and. I think they're often.
Unreasonable and also there's not a recognition that multiple occupancy. Was designed really as a form of.
Development that would provide low cost housing for low income people.
And if you impose really harsh development conditions. On to those people.
Then they're you know they're not able to comply with them for a start so they end up living in illegal situations.
And it would process. Multiple occupancy into a much more sort of middle class.
Market so you disenfranchising low income people. And you know really the only opportunity they had to.
Are in their own pace of land
and to build their own house to give them some sort of security that i believe everybody has a right to sort of lost.
The trial. Local politics. Do you want to focus on women politics. Politics in women is a very complex issue and.
Are must say.
In the fifteen months that i've been on council i've found it particularly difficult at times to come to terms with
your mate. Somebody for instance in one social situation and they'll say one thing.
And then you hear that in you know another social situation with a different group of people they've said something
quite different from a i think. My observation in him than is that the turning point in community politics.
Happened probably about two and a half years ago.
When the last federal election was held in this state which had been traditionally a national party say. Was lost.
By the national party to the labor party and. I would say that. Helen called a cop who was a long time.
Paced campaigner who stood as an independent and had a great deal of the peo to paypal in this electorate.
Was really the the k. Race in ma that was won by labor. And lost by the national party.
Subsequently to that there was a resurgence of activity. By the national party. Within this whole area and.
Name and wasn't sort of. Spared that act. That activity. At the same time in name and. They were. Paper.
Developers who'd moved into the area. Who bought up a lot of the land surrounding the village.
And who were very keen to say name and develop so that was putting a lot of pressure on women
and combined with that there was that debate about whether to put in a centralised serious came into the village. That.